well the labor MP Diane Abbott was the
first black woman elected to Parliament
and has campaigned Against Racism for
years she's also ngozi falani's MP and
uh in a tweet the MP for Hackney North
and Stoke Newington said ridiculous for
Buckingham Palace age to be so rude to
my friend and constituent and gozi
falani next thing they'll be asking me
where do you really come from and Diane
Abbott joins me now I'm pleased to say
Diane Abbott good afternoon to you
thanks so much for talking to us so as
you were saying there ngozi Fulani a
friend as well as a constituent of yours
so what's your reaction to what's
happened to her
well at first when I heard about it I
was completely shocked
um this is 2022 I mean years ago
um I I've had interactions like ngozi
had many many times they tell where
you're from I'd say London and they'd
say where are you really from uh talking
to friends this morning and we've all
had that experience but I just think in
2022 people should know better have you
been able to talk to her at all about
this
no I haven't been able to I speak spoken
to one of her colleagues at her
organization but I've not been able to
meet with her today
so maybe that will will happen as the
days and hours go on but in the meantime
Buckingham Palace were very keen to
stress yesterday weren't they that they
acted swiftly they announced quickly
that uh lady Hussey was was stepping
down they also put out some strong
statements condemning racism as did
Prince William's people as well are you
reassured At All by the promptness of
the action taken by the palace
well you have to say if this had
happened a few years ago people would
have Shrugged it off and so that ngozi
was touchy she had a chip on her
shoulder and so on and the fact that
Buckingham Palace has moved swiftly does
show a little bit of progress you have
to say that
do would you like to see more action
though from the palace
I think it's important that they
recognize what was wrong with the
interaction and the form of words one
thing I would say though is this
demonstrates so Meghan Markle wasn't
totally wrong when she said there were
issues about race in the royal family
and she was thoroughly abused by the
popular press but this sort of
vindicates what she was saying and it's
just interesting what you said that
about this having happened to you and
there has been an extraordinary
outpouring of Stories on social media
haven't there about people saying
they've had exactly the same challenges
from people saying no but where are you
really from that seems to be a question
that has come up an awful lot do you
think there needs to be a wider
conversation not just a focus on the
palace but also a wider conversation in
this country about this kind of issue
well I think the issue in this
particular conversation was the lady
just could not believe that you would be
black and British that's why she kept
asking the question over and over again
I think with younger people they are
more likely to believe that you're black
and British but I think then does need
to be a conversation about language as
well as material examples of racism and
disadvantage but there does need to be a
conversation about a language it's
interesting that you you talk about
Generations do you think that age is an
issue here there's the women in question
here at the palace Aid was in her 80s do
you think that should be taken into
account or not
well I don't know about taking it into
account it was an offensive conversation
it really was but all I'm saying is that
younger people are more likely to
believe that you can be black and
British after all the British prime
minister is of Indian descent so you
know we live in a more multiracial
Society but
however you look at it what that woman
said to ngozi was wrong and defensive
and do you think this story in itself
will raise some awareness the fact that
it's prompted conversations about
people's experiences your own
experiences people's colleagues
experiences and maybe family members as
well do you think that's there are some
positives that could come out of this
there's a raising of awareness
I hope it will raise Consciousness and
awareness because language matters and
language can be very hurtful I know that
ngozi was very hurt by that interaction
I mean she's come to Buckingham Palace
um she's hoping to have a positive time
and then almost the first encounter she
has is this woman poking around her hair
and insisting where does she really come
from
and the other thing that the Parlor said
yesterday was they said that all members
of the royal household would be that the
wedding was reminded of the diversity
and inclusivity policies which they're
required to uphold at all times do you
feel that there are enough organizations
that put enough emphasis on those kinds
of policies
I think there are a lot of public sex
organizations which ought to put more
emphasis on those policies we've seen a
report about Dreadful
um things happening in the the fire
brigades we know the issues in the
police with the things they pass amongst
themselves online I think a lot of
organizations need to be reminded that
language matters and you can't dismiss
racist language as just banter
well Diana but we really appreciate your
time this afternoon thanks so much for
joining us